scientists in far north australia  have made a startling new discovery  that has to be seen to be believed  at just nine million years old the  epaulette shark is the youngest shark  species on the planet  and look what it can do  [Music]  it has thick round muscular fins  that it can bend and use like legs  [Music]  and now this shark takes this behavior  one step further  make that many steps  the largest epaulette shark is three  feet long  it's a hearty animal that can tolerate  water so hot  it would kill any other fish  on land it slows its breathing and heart  rate  allowing it to survive for an hour or  even longer  without any water at all  the epaulette shark may be different  from a great white or a bull shark  but it's evidence of evolution  just like whales were once land animals  that return to the  ocean sharks may evolve one day  to come onto land  [Music]  you